do you think in hindsight you were you
were wrong was that was a moment of
hubris well you know the basic argument
I think was fundamentally on
misunderstood the end of history didn't
mean you know that democracy would
triumph everywhere and always and in
fact I said nationalism and religion are
going to continue to be powerful forces
the question is really what's the
direction that the whole development or
modernization process is leading towards
and for 150 years the Marxist had said
the end of history is going to be
communism that's the highest form of
society and in 1989 I'm just made a
simple observation it didn't look like
we're gonna get there that we're gonna
stop at the you know the stage before
communism which was liberal democracy
tied to a market economy and you know
the real question I was trying to ask
was is there actually a better
alternative out there because I didn't
see one I didn't see one then and quite
frankly I don't see one now when we look
back thirty years at nineteen eighty
nine you know was that the moment that's
some of what we're going through at the
moment whether it's brexit or indeed the
rise of Donald Trump or other populist
movements was that the moment that that
curve actually began well I think that
some of the policies that led to the
current backlash were laid in that
period there was a dismantling of a lot
of state institutions and a kind of
growth of a very ruthless form of market
capitalism that I think increased
economic inequality especially in
Britain and America that had adopted
these liberal policies and I think
that's kind of laid the groundwork for
what we're seeing now the economic
inequality is kind of the conventional
wisdom about why we're seeing the
backlash but I actually think the
cultural reaction is more important
because what happened as a result of
this growing inequality was a cultural
cleavage that emerged between people
that had good education --zz
opportunities were mobile could take
advantage of this new cosmopolitan world
that was opening up and people that were
more
no fix conservative and their social
values when you talk to a lot of people
who fight a Brax a part of their
frustration isn't just with the economic
story important necessarily just with
the cultural story it's also with these
technocrats in Brussels who seem to be
directing us and that again didn't kind
of pan out in in the kind of positive
way well I think that there is a sort of
snobbery and looking down your nose at
the you know the brexit voters you know
they'd be lectured you don't understand
you know you didn't take your trade
theory course and don't understand how
bad it's going to be if we go back to a
protectionist world and you know I think
a lot of them said yeah I know perfectly
well you know why I'm voting this way
because I don't want my country filling
up with foreigners I don't want to lose
my national identity and you know that's
more important to me what does brexit
say about you know the UK's place in the
world I don't really see how it can be
other than a diminution of the standing
I mean just within the United Kingdom
itself brexit is going to unloose
unleash you know a lot of tensions with
with Ireland and with with Scotland but
it also does seem to be a rejection of
you know the kind of intense leadership
role that Britain has played and part of
it was actually by being part of the
European Union you know it was really
the voice in the EU for a more
market-oriented less status set of
policies and that's being given up so
you know there's there's there's anger
in this frustration and to some extent
it feels once again like quite a scary
world that we're living in does it was
it was the last 30 years where you know
just a period a kind of you know an
aberration and you know in terms of the
world feeling more secure I don't think
that the world is about to fall apart
because actually we have pretty strong
institutions I mean we have institutions
in every individual democracy that are
much stronger than they were let's say
but in the US
grexit House of Commons is being tested
in a big way well both Britain and the
United States are going through
constitutional crises in which the you
know the political structures are being
tested by these populace that want to
break out of the bounds that have been
established my prediction is though that
they're going to hold and also I think
the international structures are not
going to go away you know NATO and the
European Union in a sense you know may
even be strengthened as a result of
going through this intense crisis but
it's very dangerous because you know
among other things the polarization in
the United States has permitted a
country like Russia to fish in these
troubled waters and to increase you know
the degree of cleavage and thereby
weaken its perceived enemies I mean the
Putin really thinks that he's at war
with the West and I think the rise of
populism gives him I kind of fifth
column with in many developed countries
developed democracies that he can use
okay well thank you talking to us today
thank you very much